[Music]
[Music]
and if i die
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i think
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the creek in the cave
a few things before we get started
please stay off your cell phones
no heckling and keep table talk to a
minimum now who's ready to see other
people
give it up
this guy he goes on a date all he does
is go on dates he's an expert in the
field give it up for your
host kid
[Music]
thank you guys for coming out tonight
it's the day after christmas uh
none of you are with your family
so
[ __ ] them you know it's time for us to
make our own with a nice
nice uh sexual date
uh but good to be here uh my name is
hans kim this is a show where you put
your name in a bucket and then we pick
it out and then two people go on a date
and then we get to know you guys a
little better afterwards
with a little interview portion uh
hopefully there's enough dudes here a
lot of girls showed up which is fine uh
but anyways speaking of girls this next
comic is also a girl and i was a huge
fan of her on kill tony and now she's uh
here i got to book on my show and i get
to sit next to her give it up for
brittany ledesma
this wasn't a ploy just to go on a date
with brittany
i say that every episode i only have
girls up oh it's this guy again
some one of you lucky ladies forget to
go on a date with this guy very very
funny guy um
hopefully he won't tell the story about
how he vomited during sex again
yikes bro
uh but
but it was it was very a very funny
story you got to hear him tell you you
had to be there
kidding
uh thank you guys so uh brittany are you
excited to watch people today excited
what are you most excited about
uh seeing it probably go wrong
yeah when they ask the dude ask the girl
how old she is oh yeah i hate it when
that happens
i often do it
um
but uh yeah i uh i can't wait to see
dates go on an awkward date instead of
just us me uh
god damn
what's better than a normal day
uh normal what's better than a normal
date it's probably
a
an abnormal date there's only one woman
who signed up you know all these women
are here i think
more of you guys should sign up
just to
[Music]
get more names in the bucket so we can
watch more people go on dates
there's two more dudes here so if you
want to watch dudes who make a fool of
you or fool themselves then please sign
up uh because it'll be really funny you
just have to sit there brittany will be
on your side anyways this uh first date
coming out give it up for samantha and
tyler
[Applause]
there's samantha you could go around
this side through the door
uh tyler
brown comedian
he's a very funny guy
who's excited for this
make some noise if you're excited to
watch people date
and not have to do it yourself
okay you guys get one minute to date
each other and go ahead and date
hi i'm tyler nice to meet you samantha
nice to meet you nice to meet you
so uh let's see let's get into the real
stuff let's do it um how dark was your
childhood
should we get a drink first yeah i
forgot to bring my beer me too me too
can we get a bartender all right
so um um yeah it was pretty dark we
didn't have a lot of electricity cool
yeah either i grew up in alabama
oh nice texas here so nice nice nice
back when austin was cool okay so you're
a local i am
damn yeah
all right so uh let's see what else what
was your name again tyler oh is he rude
i don't know i remember your name
they're watching
that's how i see how old people are if
they can right if they can remember that
yeah
if they get the reference
all right 15 seconds left oh [ __ ] what
was your childhood like uh i mean i just
i don't know i mean i i got beat a lot
as a child
single mother she was you know nice yeah
but i forgave her you know i got over
she's people her people hurt people
that's what they say right yeah
that's a good one
did you deserve it though maybe i was an
[ __ ] i'm sure
and time
give it up for these two and it was
getting good
ending on deserve to get beat i thought
that was a good time to interrupt
what were you like as a kid tyler uh
surprisingly compact
and then you grew into the man you are
today
that's wonderful to hear uh you asked
her
if she had a dark childhood and then
where she was from and then you ran out
of things to say yeah i don't that was
like that was one thing i'd forgotten
or started or thought to ask but then uh
everything else blanked out so is that
something you normally ask on a first
date no not at all i was just get
straight to the point
but you know you're playing it up for
the crowd yeah i mean that was the idea
right it's a show i'd say try to get
laid
yeah
i say try to have a good date i mean
thinking of my childhood doesn't make me
want to [ __ ] yeah i don't think that
makes her put me wet depends on it if it
does my father unless the conversation
goes that way then yeah i don't know
it's a childhood i always love a good
childhood talk yeah on a date
so uh how was your childhood like any uh
sex happening
um
yeah i guess i don't know like
i i dry humped at 10 and then nice
was he passed out was he
they're awful at sex he had a dark
childhood yeah
what was wrong with him why why was he
crying um
he just was jealous of the pillow that i
was driving
that's understandable that's very intel
like
uh
so he was okay i don't understand why he
didn't like you were willing to have
intercourse with this man this boy
oh
you weren't that intense seems like she
preferred the pillow
yeah
you know you go back to what you know
well that's kind of hot to do it in
front of someone yeah yeah anyways uh
this is weird to talk about because my
niece and nephew are with me hey
niece and nephew when did you guys start
dry humping
[Laughter]
you guys should sign up for a day we
won't make you go on a date together
uh
we thought this is an alabama todd if we
did get drawn together we were kind of
hoping
some incestuous lannister type [ __ ]
they have a lot to talk about yeah the
red comedy up here
the red comedy
oh the red wedding
the red comedy see how you pull it back
around that's what comics do yeah yeah
do callbacks yeah to shows
that aired 10 years ago
um the red comedy so you would kill up
here you kill everyone on stage or
something yeah
yeah
so what do you do for work
oh that's so boring
no i feel like that's a first date
question i know tell us a lot about
yourself
yeah it's only boring if your job is
boring it is boring
what's your boring job i'm an office
manager at a mortgage company
that money you got that office chair you
make money sitting down tyler does not
he wears carhartt he works in the field
with his hands i teach math virtually
i'm a math teacher also pretty boring i
guess
you're shaping lives yeah
at risk youth facilities so they need it
they need some extra shaping you know
now you're just bragging and you got
plenty of shape there for it
whoa fat joke
uh so you work at home maybe you can
manage him you guys could have an office
romance
he's he needs some managing some office
management i could order him a new chair
that'd be helpful or do an expense
report for him
accounting making sure your taxes are
all in order
get on my write-ups and check yeah i'll
just skim off the top a little bit okay
so let's do a little improv exercise
let's do a little exercise where you
guys are both working in the office
tyler is one of your top
teachers
and you are managing him
and uh you've noticed a little uh little
uh
expenditure that's not accounted for and
you're you're confronting him at his
office
and scene and go to action
uh yes come on in tyler we need to have
a conversation what can i do for you
samantha well i noticed on the uh
business credit card there are a lot of
charges at bed bath and beyond and i
want to know how many pillows you bought
to dry home
exfoliation is key
no pillows no pillows
well you know they don't really make one
in my size so i had to buy several
in order to
properly you know mount cool cool we can
justify that one yeah i also noticed an
exorbitant amount of charges to the
creek and cave and i just didn't know
what that place was and why you're
spending
so much money there well uh
someone must have stolen my credit card
and scene wow we were really taken there
give it up for that
little flight of fancy that we all went
on
i felt like i was actually there
your office is covered in pillows for
some reason you're just masturbating and
dry humping all all day when you're
supposed to be working
uh where's the weirdest place that you
masturbated in tyler
well for being truthful
obviously
well as a child i went to like this
magnet program i'm not trying to brag
but it was just like hours away so
they'd pick me up at like five in the
morning and i'd be the only kid on the
back of the bus for like two hours i
think you were special i just didn't
tell you that's it yeah
yeah uh and so one day it was you know
like or in early in the morning dark bus
drivers way up there deciding sexy yeah
take care of myself you know the
vibration of the bus yeah that was it
that's awesome you masturbated in a bus
as a child a lot of childhood sex talk
on this date
um
what is uh
what who is your first boyfriend
samantha
um
his name was benji
oh yeah
um like the dog
sounds exotic [ __ ] dog that he was
i'm not bitter there's some pain he
cheated he did she
never trusted benji i know never they're
too free
he did take me to a brooks and then
concert though so was this in high
school or college she was in high school
okay and he's he's not the one that was
crying next to you
no
not that the one that was that was only
like two weeks ago
oh wow
it's kind of
weird
as an old man you should have uh you
should have figured out you shouldn't be
crying in bed who said he was old
i mean
so you [ __ ] the high schooler she did
say she wasn't going to because you're
doing the age thing so it makes sense
there's only a couple weeks ago
oops
but uh yeah this is going out live on
the internet so maybe not admit to any
felonies
hey mom yeah
so
where would where do you guys see
yourselves going on a date maybe a
bookstore library
yeah i guess we didn't really get into
interest so we got kind of bogged down
in the trauma that's true uh well yeah
what are you what are you into
we could um like walk the hike and bike
trail and
count tents all right
that sounds fun yeah yeah nice hobbies
yeah it's like people watching i think
so it's good exercise active exercise
yes
yeah yeah yeah maybe i have to fight off
some people we can see how chivalrous
you are yeah i got robbed by a homeless
man ooh get your attention
the other day it was a few days ago what
did he steal from you well i set my
wallet on the bench like an idiot i'm
sitting there waiting for my food so he
didn't steal he just yeah i know yeah he
thieved
i don't know what yeah
burglared spurgled i don't know
hopefully he didn't start dry humping
the wallet
hopefully not well you know it was a
kind it was a kind robbing
because he picked up the wallet took all
the cash out of it and then put the
wallet back down oh that was kind of
like best of both worlds he's like but
thanks did he leave your vaccination
card
or did he take it no he needed that to
get into it so he didn't notice this he
took it and he brought it back and you
didn't notice the whole time well i had
stood up with my food and walked to a
different restaurant and he saw my
wallet laying there alone he was like
but if i seen a motor
gone fisty cuffs you know it's good to
know yeah you want to know that your man
can uh
fight for whatever
right tyler have you ever been in a
fight before
my whole life you know
but in like a real physical way well no
yeah actually like i grew up fighting a
lot
i grew up in a like a predominantly
african-american neighborhood and they
they liked to see if they could and
you're racist
you went around clobbering them yeah
that was it yeah uh you you got in a lot
of fights i'm sure that you were the
good guy and some of it no uh yeah
anyway so i got picked on a lot you know
so i just fought back i just defended
myself that's i'm not i was always
taught never start a fight but you damn
well better finish it that's good okay
that's what about or run away yeah a rag
ass flea yeah but i don't think that's
an option did you ever kick him in the
nuts or uh i've i've slapped a couple of
nuts well that's that was like more of
like
a couple kick seems a little aggressive
i don't know
slapping nuts just like nut tapping yeah
with your friends naked together in a
closet
yeah after watching together yeah and
then everyone get a pillow yeah yeah one
thing i always
like to know on the first day is like
what their top three worst qualities are
y'all should exchange that now
uh well
fat
okay that's one depressed mostly because
of the fat you know okay uh
and i smoked too much wheat i guess
there we go
that makes you fat
well exactly so it's just like a real
symbiotic thing you know my three cycles
yeah
anything that we can't see i guess
depression anything that we can't see
and if you don't tell the truth we'll
ask them yeah um
i just i love really hard
i just love her
i just care too much your niece does not
believe you what did you get what did
she get you for christmas what did you
get she really loves people
okay she cares that's not bad that
smells scary
that's better than 20. 20 is average i
would say or a present you don't want
you know everyone wants money thank you
that's all i like she does love heart
and the second worst thing about you
um
i'm early to everything these are all
sounding like backdoor brags
together
oh my god i work i have a i have a
normal job i make money i have a
paycheck i'm like i'm falling apart over
here she's like wow
and i currently live with my mother
oh
that's not good because
that's what i was supposed to do
okay so
oh you so you're helping your mom's
living with you you're like oh my mom
needed help
i'm so nice i'm taking care of someone
being a nice person yeah wow what a
weakness
so what a flop such a bad person
samantha why are you living with your
mother
and i'm horribly depressed also
sick
backing off of his thing now
he has weed if you need help with that
right so we could all smoke weed
uh you guys seem like a great couple um
i think that uh your energy is very calm
and soothing and tyler's energy is very
that much as the same but also sort of
like
you know like hey i'm not gonna
apologize for myself and you know
yeah i think you all should get married
and have kids tonight yeah she loves
heart
you guys seem like you would
oh my god
tyler why don't you tell us more about
being a drug dealer
uh that was many many moons ago many
moons ago he used to deal drugs in
hawaii or something no i sold the drugs
in florida so that i could move to
hawaii
that's worth it yeah yeah
anything to get out of florida
pretty much yeah and what did you what
is what are the three commandments three
quick commandments of drug dealing in
florida
uh don't sell to some [ __ ] rando
you'll get your
[ __ ] [ __ ] up um yeah don't leave no
don't get it don't yeah there it is yeah
don't get high in your own supply i
suppose would be good that's good for
cocaine and molly yeah the weeds not so
much you can buy pounds
so does that mean that like if you have
a [ __ ] ton of molly to sell and you want
to go out one night and take some molly
you're not not going to take the [ __ ]
you have you're going to go find another
drug dealer well if i'm going
i don't know what
[Music]
was she doing this yesterday at your
christmas party
oh no what uh what'd you what happened
last night at the christmas party with
your niece and nephew oh [ __ ] so we my
brother has that vr
thing and so i was doing this like you
walk across a plank on a skyscraper and
it's virtual reality so it's basically
your reality at the moment
and i was like okay i'm gonna fall off
i'm gonna fall off and then all of a
sudden i felt my brother and he pushed
me and there's a video of it and i just
slam my head up against the wall and i
slam down on the ground oh no
that sounds like a crime
are you concussed you sound concussive i
feel concussed my knees are bruised
so what's up
[Laughter]
or from uh the guy that uh benji benji
i mean yeah
yeah
is now from high school
my heart is
oh that was deep
so is he like your first boyfriend that
uh
now like it impacted like your love life
significantly or
yeah
it's just something fun to say
yeah i mean he was my first boyfriend he
cheated and i slapped him and then we
broke up that's actually way more mature
than most of my breakups yeah well it's
probably the most mature breakup i've
ever had at 43 now so yeah it's just
gone downhill yeah i mean uh nowadays
it's like you cheat you get back
together they cheat again so
high schoolers are way more advanced
than us
uh anything uh embarrassing that you
would reveal on a first date
tyler how would you go first on this one
piercing
i think i already pretty much told you
all of it uh you masturbated in a bus
that's a good one you dealt drugs in
florida yeah that's another good one
you got robbed yeah yeah um
yeah yeah that's that was yeah that's
pretty much the what are you all
whispering about do you all know what i
should be embarrassed about
what is it
divorced
getting divorced in 2021 dude your
family is brutal why don't you go put on
the scarlet letter wow
my best friend right now is my
most recent ex-husband
maybe you should have slapped him and
walked away like he did benji
we actually talked about him coming with
us tonight and how hilarious it would be
if he and i got on a date together
it's not too late let's call him up
let's see what he's up to
typical ex-husband [ __ ]
ex-husbands always get covered they're
always out
at the jackalope coughing on someone
uh what went wrong with that marriage
it's good to know you
yeah what went wrong with that marriage
um
we grew apart i lied to him about money
money money money money and sex
he wanted way too many blow jobs
that i think is a girlfriend thing not a
wife thing yeah you married him so you
didn't have to give him [ __ ] anymore
yeah i mean it was part of the vows but
a little guy
smart man putting that in uh writing
yeah um yeah i mean money is important
did you lie about having too much or too
little um i lied about having too little
i like fighting money yeah
i was hiding money in credit card debt
but it was yours right yeah but it was
affecting his credit
everything's coming out
did you know this
no
[Laughter]
they're getting to know their aunt today
yeah that's awesome it's a nice bonding
experience learning about her rubbing
against pillows
i didn't think i'd be up here this time
yeah this is a long time
to be up here without alcohol
so you uh you got a lot of debt uh
shopping or
yeah i was just shopping my emotions
nice
yeah that made that happen
that's awesome i mean uh you know it's
not easy to hide money it's like
actually an art form a lot of drug
dealers do it tyler you guys could
blonder money together yeah it works
you just
have large amounts of cash and uh and
take it internationally and then spend
it all there
they don't really ask questions about
where you got it right right
that's what you should have done
it is
in thailand it's like super dirt cheap
gonna retire right now are you asking me
to run away with you yeah let's do this
sorry kids
it's awesome money you're uh you're a
very smooth criminal well uh until you
got caught
it's because i'm white though i wouldn't
give it to
myself you know i don't think i did
anything extra uh i think it's just
because i was talking about samantha
i don't want getting away with the drug
dealing but all right
yeah tyler is a drug dealer you're a
uh you know ponzi spezzler
uh
made in heaven uh thank you guys so much
for coming on you guys are the first day
give it up for this lovely couple
[Applause]
just two dudes yeah do you might have to
do two dudes i think uh
this guy is a dude
jack mcclellan
signed up
in the lgbtqia bucket
do you want to go on a date with a woman
instead
okay he does not care hopefully he's b
okay good if you're a g then it would be
kind of
kind of a homophobic to make you go on a
date with a girl this is actually a dude
oh we only have dudes left oh yeah you
can go on a
dude date with cody
hey
cody's down
little bromance a little bromance you
know
let's get to know these two bros let's
bro it down bros
two dudes talking about each other let's
go cody how's it going jack jack nice to
meet you good to meet you
uh what are you for living i am i work
at a mortgage brokerage with my hand
yeah nice yeah i'm an assistant big
bucks okay tell me about like mortgage
life like should i buy a house right now
or should i
no okay you see how much they cost in
austin so the real estate question will
i be able to buy a house oh [ __ ] future
ever or if you're here no i'm [ __ ] oh
damn
there go those dreams what about you
what do you do i i work for a video game
company oh [ __ ] which one uh it's called
cloud imperium games um yeah no one's
heard of it that's fine it's better that
way because i answer support tickets all
day so if anybody has heard of it they
start coming up to me and start asking
me questions about it i'm just going to
want to punch them
fair enough
uh i answer those questions all day i
don't want to do it when i'm fair enough
nobody wants to talk about their work
[ __ ] work yeah for sure
um but
that being said i do enjoy my work
it's lots of fun do you enjoy your work
i'm contractually obligated to say yes
right especially
yeah right and time give it up for this
date
oh my
way to go guys
oh wait one last question top or bottom
uh top oh damn damn sorry i can't wait
two tops
guys it'll be bumping bumping dicks
tonight we can hump some pillows yeah
that'll work
you guys can pump the same pillow
ass to ass
pillow to pillow
you know what you think about gay
relationships wow
it's mostly from requiem for a dream
um
so you guys are two dudes uh you work in
tech uh
do you
do you always enjoy it did you always
enjoy computers and are you kind of a
nerd
yes
yes nice like to an embarrassing degree
i was very nerdy
trying to kind of shed that it was very
too square fit too much in that square
hole yeah
so you grew out your hair and now you
have a goatee uh yes i called me a
hippie and i'm trying to lean into that
okay i'll work with that he's a nerdy
hippie
uh so have you ever been on a gay date
before
once
and how to go it was okay that was how i
figured out that i'm not hardcore
leaning into the men that it's no men
maybe they're leaning hard into you
what was that sorry i said maybe they're
leaning hard into you they might have
been
but you're at top uh did you uh did you
enjoy your date with uh
this guy
[Laughter]
how would you all rate each other
jack
uh like on what scale yeah like on an
attraction scale on a kinsey scale
personality and looks can be combined so
yeah for like one out of ten one to ten
one two one
for both of y'all right now
i'd say like a six seven yeah yeah let's
say six seven yeah wow nice
[Music]
they both see each other in the same
same way i see sparks right now
that handshake i know they're going to
be too similar because you look like
this is way more chemistry than thai oh
god
uh if you guys succeed you guys get to
go on a date with uh samantha
try and win your aunt back
so
what do you guys uh
think about
you know do you have any plans for new
year's [ __ ] each other
my god
i liked his question more
i'm going to waco yeah what about you
uh no i don't have any plans for new
year's i was hoping to maybe meet
someone here
to have a more serious date you want to
take cody to waco with you yeah you want
to go to a wedding with me i don't know
anybody there
maybe
i haven't worn my suit to a happy
occasion in a long time
i've only been to funerals the last
three years
this is the dark childhood tyler was
talking about
no this is just a dark life this is a
dark man
a man of mystery working in tech let's
do worse qualities for y'all top three
let's see i also smoke too much weed
that can't be worse quality no
let's see i i smoke too much weed to the
point where i'm bad with my money is
that important that a bad have you ever
sucked dick to get some weed no haven't
gotten that doesn't sound like it's a
problem
just say i i'm i'm poor with managing my
money
uh
let's see
other words qualities uh i'm an early
riser like obscenely early i wake up at
five six o'clock pretty regularly
um
and gross
yeah
yeah but same it looks like we're even
getting closer
you guys could have morning sex
[Laughter]
hopefully it won't throw up on you
yes i've i'm playing jack
does it worry you to know that your uh
aunt slash boss was caught for
hiding credit card debt
as a as in a business sense like maybe
your business is in danger because she's
an assistant now i can blackmail her for
more money nice you're an assistant no
you're this is like the lannisters
yes if you're on the papers
you're an accomplice now exactly it's
too late to blackmail her he wants in on
your scam
always
is it all in the family yep it's her
brother
my father
nepotism as hell oh my god it's great
it's a mafia family
you guys are just selling houses as a
family
no we give people money so they can buy
houses uh owe them moments
so a bunch of people owe us money it's
great
have you ever had to repo anything
personally yeah no have you ever had to
assign someone a repo something
i just got into it like
nine months ago
there's nothing on your wrist is that a
risk calendar what was i gonna show you
oh yeah my hairs have grown that long
see what's horrible is i do that same
thing sometimes we're watching oh my god
see sparks are flying oh my god
do you i want you to carry this energy
on the next female date you have you're
doing great right now for a dude i feel
like this is wasted i told you you could
be saving this you guys said the last
one it's all just i'm paranoid
constantly it's all yeah that's another
bottle another one of your uh fault
backfalls fall down yeah that's it
faults i have
zero confidence i fake it until i make
it and i haven't made it yet i mean
that's the way to do it
you work in tech brittany said all you
tech guys look the same now yeah every
tech guy looks like they could also be
homeless yeah i've been mistaken for a
homeless man by another homeless man
it's like your way of rebelling like a
14 year old does to go to goth stuff
well so the best part about when i first
got my job i was previously a substitute
teacher and that was my entire wardrobe
so i actually was brought into my
manager's office and he said okay you
haven't gotten the clue this is after
about a week and a half of working there
and wearing not quite a suit but like a
jacket
he said you haven't gotten the clue on
the dress code yet you're overdressed it
was like here's some cold cash now go
ham that was almost a conversation
because i was waiting on my first
paycheck to buy new clothes that weren't
so you're closer to your substitute
clothes are better than your tech
clothes yes not
damage why available it a problem
anyways i i think it's great that uh
they were like i need you to dress down
yes fit in more
uh what would you wear to a date and why
did you wear that tonight
i would definitely dress a little nicer
and i wore this because i've learned not
to take these seriously you look like uh
the logo for bing
thank you
you like this look like halo it's colder
in here than it is this evening
yeah i'm expecting it normally to be
rather chilly i guess it's sort of it's
like a very tech christmas sweater it's
it's actually licensed merchandise for
the video game
oh my god you're wearing your own merch
i got it for free so i really couldn't
you know
it's warm and it's reasonably high
quality so i'm like okay it works
i wouldn't expect anything less from a
man wearing a bandana
wearing free clothes
whatever the economy gives you that's
what you look like i think that's
wonderful
uh so what did you uh
what was it like for you growing up when
was your first
boyfriend slash girlfriend when did you
know that you were gonna sign up at the
lgbtqia plus bucket
oh i was at a party drunk at 20 and i
just look at this guy he looks at me
and we start making out it was kind of
weird
nice and we stopped making out and i go
i've never kissed a guy before and he
runs away he just ran and yeah that's
the thing about those games they're very
flighty yeah they just run you gotta
catch him the first guy i kissed was at
the renaissance festival and he hung out
with me for too long after that
you wish you ran away there needs to be
a good balance between that your your
first kiss and your first it was cool
for about a half an hour and i'm like
all right you've been hanging out with
me for a while and i'm not feeling it
anymore and he's still just hanging out
with me now you know what it's like to
be a woman
like oh just because i blew you doesn't
mean i want to marry you and hide credit
card debt from you
[Laughter]
but uh yeah i mean i love a good uh i
love a good clingy story have you ever
been the clingy one or have you always
been clung on to
i think i was the cleaning one in my
last relationship more sunk cost fallacy
than cling but
there was i definitely hung out there a
lot longer than i should have you're
gambling
yeah on the relationship you're trying
to double down double or nothing
uh i mean uh what about you are you
usually the clinger or clung on too
usually i just kind of forget that they
exist for like 10 hours and then i'm
like oh [ __ ] i have a girlfriend or a
boyfriend and then they like yeah it
just happens
nice
yeah the video game oh you like video
games perfect
he's a gamer ladies he works at a video
game company you all should
we should develop
develop a project together it's called
love
i am in the
entry level area wanting to get out of
the entry level area it's like i want to
make the more money not the
yeah that's what he's trying to do with
you tonight get out of this entry level
area
i want to develop something in your
pants i want to develop something in
your exit level area
nice
so how many uh
straight relationships and how many gay
relationships would you say 70 30 20 20
20 80. um
are we counting grinder
yeah yes just you guys just [ __ ] yeah
like they they know what to do i've
never been in a relationship with a guy
only girls i've just
[ __ ] more guys
yeah that's just kind of how it works
they're just they're just masturbation
tools women are
for love men are for
pleasure
jesus you're just using and abusing us
cox
yeah it's great
have you ever had a dick in your ass
you said you were in touch wow
how does this make you feel samantha
your nephew
was recently penetrated
austin that's like a brag though yeah
that's how you the family members you
have here the better that's how you get
your fast pass at the d.o.t they
stick a [ __ ] in your ass
that's actually how uh
that's how jack got vaccinated
johnson and johnson
of the anus
but uh
so you would you say like mostly uh
mostly dudes for like first time hookups
but like women for like long term
yeah okay yeah i mean it's just easier
you know you just go on grinder and
you're just like hey yo and then on
tinder it's all like oh buy me dinner
yeah you know yeah they're always so
demanding i always
want to go out to a restaurant
who does that i know these are savages
yeah i would i would much rather have a
quick uh pump and chug and dunk
pump and dump what are you doing grinder
then
oh i think this guy is like a bot i
think he's a commercial for grindr
he's convincing me
call me an npc
yeah he calls you a russian
uh
so cody uh
any any embarrassing sex stories besides
this time you vomited on a woman
yes
they're all usually much longer though
how about a quick cliff notes trying to
think of how to abbreviate it
any uh bodily fluids
yes okay here we go so one of the the
first times i was having sex
uh we were you cried while your date
humped it down
it was probably like two when that
happened
very young man
maybe close
um
no uh one of the first times i took one
of my previous relationships uh to a
hotel because i was too poor to have my
own apartment or car or anything we were
we agreed to meet at the hotel and i
don't know how they got there would you
pay her money i think this was a
prostitute no
no we we knew each other um we had gone
to high school together um but i i
actually had my parents drop me off
there
there was a convention at the hotel
oh so they thought you were going to the
convention chad yeah they thought you
were being a loser not getting laid
turns out you were getting laid that's
the only reason you were there
oh that's a positive spin on it i'm glad
my date's a winner oh yeah
thank you yeah anyway he'll buy you a
hotel room
he makes it happen so you've you had sex
with this person in a hotel room
i did but then uh mid sex we lost the
condom
uh inside of her and it took
did you think you were like an xl or
something
i guess i don't know it was not the
first time but it was still probably
early enough on that i was still
figuring out that size does matter in
that sense you have to choose the
correct size condom
uh but in any case after like i don't
know half an hour of not quite foreplay
it was like this just isn't hot or fun
i think the beginning of my disillusion
with the sex
oh [ __ ] you're disillusioned with sex
you really are a tech bro
oh it's so sad so you were digging
around
in this high school uh alumni's vagina
uh and you found her found the condom
yeah after a while
did she come at any point in this
medical procedure no
i don't believe so
maybe you could have played with a [ __ ]
while you were digging around inside
there was more concern going on because
after the first
two minutes three minutes it was more of
a okay no it needs to eventually we have
to find this
were your hands and her trying to find
it like a doctor or was she just taking
care of it we took turns she couldn't
reach i couldn't reach
did y'all end up having to get like a
pin or something to get it out of here
you know fishing it's there
maybe a coat hanger
no
we do texas abortion you know handle the
fetus too while you're at it did manage
to get a handle on it eventually
nice
and uh
did you end up having sex with her after
that or were you like i'm excited no we
had a relationship for about a year two
years after that oh my god yeah that was
i guess that was a traumatic
bonded to the experience and we used it
as code to
like hey we're going to go fishing yeah
let's go fishing and
that was our code you want to go [ __ ]
well yeah let's go [ __ ]
go fishing again just like the condom
inside her yes except we hope that we
never that's a great way if you guys
ended up uh getting engaged you could
just drop a wedding ring inside her
vagina and be like
honey remember how he first had sex
i'm gonna need you to dig around again i
would have married her but no
give it up for cody and jack
cody the spelunker
next time bring a headlamp
we got a
lot more women signed up maybe we'll
have cody come back up here
he can go spelunking inside you ladies
uh
here's a arrow
arrow will go on a date because there's
so many women now
uh we got nikki coming up going on a
date with brad b
nikki and brad b
[Applause]
here come the lovely couple i feel
sparked nikki's
nikki's a little cautious a little
hesitation
in the moment
it's a very nerve-wracking
to come all the way up here
we very much appreciate all the
detestants
you're gonna do great up here nikki
brad is a gentleman he's waiting
on you
he's gonna pull out the chair or
something
look at him what a good boy
wow
okay there was no point in you standing
up this whole time that was just creepy
but the intent was there
it was very beautiful gesture
nikki and brad b going on a date and
let's see them do it hi nice to meet you
nikki i'm brad
what's something that you're like
extremely passionate about
[Music]
so uh are you all like open poly this is
austin
i mean i'm a little bit i'm pretty
convincing
i think i can convince him excellent
what's his name yeah cody cody cool cody
if uh he's not here perfect even better
so do you often go on uh single dates
without cody
no this is first time oh cool i feel
very lucky yeah i should i've never done
this before
um i have another
do you think that there's anything any
such thing as too many [ __ ]
i mean yeah
yeah
all right well uh
i i'm very uh happy for you and cody
this is awesome uh
yeah uh are you from austin
i'm from fort worth and actually fun
fact it's my friend's birthday
happy birthday friend your name is nikki
as well isn't that weird oh my goodness
nikki and nikki and cody is this like a
drop hole
[Music]
hey
come on guys give it up for these this
couple
thank you she wanna she broke her sacred
vows to go on this date
we gotta give it up for them
i like how you try to imply that uh
nikki and cody were [ __ ] her other
friend nikki
and then she just coasted right over
that
well nikki's on a date with me right now
so i was wondering how open they were
trying to test the test of the strength
of this marriage really good girlfriends
oh that sounded a little sexual
how good of a girlfriend's are you
have you seen each other naked
of course
oh yeah that's just obviously that's we
all do that
right brad yeah
you've seen me naked a couple times i
think yeah i've seen your [ __ ] yeah what
all your friends naked uh
well i try to
brad is bi by the way he's uh he's out
there he's a predator
he's what the republicans are afraid of
in the bathrooms this is true they are
very afraid of me he's a bisexual long
hair
so have you before you met your husband
did you uh have any uh kissed uh kissed
a woman or anything like that
not um that i remember
maybe
so yes
yeah
try keeping the mic close to your mouth
it didn't seem like that big of a crowd
[Laughter]
it's uh
picked up on the computer
there's actually about 20 people
listening online so oh good hello 20
people
big difference i'll keep it up i'll keep
it close yeah maybe your husband's
watching he might want to hear all this
you should let him know hi cody does he
have covid or
no it's girls night out tonight you guys
are it's birthday birthday night
birthday night
yeah so nikki's it's nikki's birthday
did she sign up did you sign her up i
signed all of us up
so how do you know i called you and not
the other nikki i mean
she took one for the team
it is her birthday yeah so you're like
i'll take this one yeah but you know
you're gonna get called if you're
there's only two of you in the bucket so
it's gonna happen let me know if you
want to go on a date with a woman
because
that might be fun
but uh yeah i mean uh what what uh
what was your uh dating life like uh in
uh high school college oh really intense
intense pretty fun
nicki can tell you put the mic up closer
pretend it's
not no it was good my husband and i have
known each other for a long time so i
actually i know a lot of people he dated
i dated a lot it was nice
nice i don't feel like i missed out on
anything i know you're not going to
believe this but the mic has to be even
closer to your face
just as close as brad is right now
i mean this is covered times right yeah
i know that uh you said you don't think
[ __ ] are important or something no
no i said there there can be too many
there can be too many that's true
yeah yeah
well what about like your favorite food
can there be too much
parmesan
lasagna
oh okay
yeah i guess that makes sense um brad
what is your favorite uh gender to go on
a date with
oh out of the 72
um
i'd have to say women are probably my
number one yeah oh what a classical
straight answer hey
you're not that bi
um yeah have you had a dick in your ass
i've not
you're not
what a great question
pansexual
pansexual yeah i think you know i mean
you get panned sexually how old are you
um oh this is a little forward i'm 35.
oh okay wow that's brave i uh
i i'm throwing women never do that
i think i think everybody that's 30
kind of feels just all over the place
right you just like it all just men
women doesn't matter uh desperation i
think is really good
just somebody
yeah absolutely i'm a queen song over
here
we got jack sitting in the audience have
you seen him on grindr before
never
do you all live close by isn't that how
it is so many miles
like one mile
oh
you like to keep it within walking
distance
it's a buyer's market out there it looks
like 15 feet away there's a closet back
there
yeah
that's how grinder works yeah you guys
are gay you have no standards you can't
say no
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] listen to online we're gonna we
might have to bleep that part out yeah
you're lucky you've gotta it's live
right
so um
uh nikki uh so were you in a sorority in
college were you like one of the cool
kids or were you like outside of the
system being a rebel i uh i'm a rebel
do you see these shoes
yeah they look
pretty non-rebellious honestly
i'm a rebel i found these on pinterest
they look pretty fancy
uh
what do you do for work i'm a medical
ass and a aesthetician oh gosh i hope
you're better at doing your job than
pronouncing it
i am i'm i'm much better at doing it
than pronouncing it yes so what do you
do exactly like botox
like lasers and needling and resurfacing
and
peels and
body contouring and so you knock them
out and then she makes people pretty i
make people pretty yeah you're a surgeon
no
i'm an esthetician oh esther okay i
thought you said a nested test like an
anesthesiologist no okay yeah you okay
i've had full-blown conversations with
people i'm thinking i'm an
anesthesiologist no i'm not oh yeah
classic mistake yeah
uh so you contour you buff buff out some
of the dents yep
you replace away some of those years yep
nice
i have no this is your field i feel out
of my depth right now okay
well i mean what does brad do
yeah
oh uh
she's got her [ __ ] figured out
a husband and everything yeah
what are you bringing yeah she has her
life together come on a date with a
husband
yeah i've been trying to be a gigolo
recently it's not working out but
uh no i'm uh
recently started as a barista um
yeah
thank you appreciate that that's like
the new pool boy i don't drink coffee
oh i make tea as well really good tea
matcha um
okay
we're doing an improv exercise and
you're the barista and you're a customer
uh your husband's not with you and you
kind of fancy brad how would how how
that what would that look like
and
action
hi how's it going hi how are you
i'm better now good
i'm gonna need something really hot
and creamy
i've got just what you're looking for
and
[Music]
with a little bit of a twist
do you like mocha
sure yeah
we're all hot though you wouldn't
believe it it's the hottest mocha in
town oh good good very dark uh
surprisingly
uh
how uh how frothy would you like it
i need it real thick perfect
uh
and
how strong
like all the way to a 10 all the way are
you trying to stay up all night all of
it yep
yep do you think you can keep going that
long yeah absolutely
and seen
damn
that was really hot
that made me
get creamy and frothy in my pants
uh see my husband isn't is it neglected
yeah i mean that'd be awesome
so you uh apparently you you offered a
mocha flavor offering your black friend
to go on a date with or do you have a
black dick yeah what i didn't understand
yeah it's oddly it's uh not it's
surprisingly colored
whoa
get that looked at buddy
let's get you in a hospital
it's blown up i hope that the
the coffee shop gives you good
healthcare um
so have you uh
is that what what environment do you
find like yourself like finding the most
eligible bachelors of bachelorettes at
do you have like a favorite place in
public
to
make eyes with strangers
what
because i've always found bookstores to
be in my jam
bookstores um
yeah bookstores where do you go sit to
look at people yeah where do you people
watch a predatory way
uh i
i don't have a whole lot of success with
that um
i
he always gets caught
yeah um i don't know i i guess bars i i
don't know
bars
my best chance
anyways i won't make you answer that so
uh what where did you meet your husband
and uh what did he do on the first date
that really sealed the deal
so we've known each other we knew each
other in high school we didn't date
we dated later in life after we had our
experiences
uh
we got together right before our 10-year
reunion
you know yeah and uh that was fun
and then uh then we got married and i
got pregnant it was real
wow
texas love story yeah have you all been
together
seven years
okay
how old were you y'all when you all got
married
28 29.
so
what do you mean by experiences after
you guys had your experiences you got
that
you know you have to [ __ ] in life before
you get married how do i know he's the
best
that's how i know that's good you took a
sample yeah i sampled it and i decided
as an aesthetician small sample size of
the general population
tried out all the dicks and found out
well it just found out i should have
just stuck it around in my hometown
yeah
some good old texas [ __ ]
um cody i hope is doing well what is
cody like is he anything like bret brad
no
tell us about what general like what
does he look like
personality
the biggest flaw
is he watching did you tell him
i don't know i don't know
biggest flaw but no he doesn't look like
you
a little bit his hair was probably about
as long as yours not too recently
he was really going for a bullet there
for a while would you say he's a stoner
or a jock or a
rebel without a cause he's a little bit
of a stoner a little bit of a drunk
not drunk
he's defined it by the drugs that he
does
um so he's a drunk stoner
i think you have a chance brad
thank you hans i appreciate the uh start
doing heroin or something
just compete with him yeah uh but thank
you guys so much for coming up on stage
and going on a date i hope your marriage
survives this nice to meet you nicki i'm
sure it will
we got another lovely couple coming up
this is a straight man bucket and
we got errol
the sexy sexy rasputin man
and then we got one or two names coming
up and it's going to be
tati
tatiana
tati is that you there's only two people
in the bucket i know all of you and what
you look like tati or the other nikki
tazzy apparently
oh my god
going on a date with a man
who lives in a van
you don't always have to introduce me
that way man
he's an angry man that lives everyone
give it up for tazzy and errol they're
gonna talk to each other
let's pick up the mics first
[Applause]
and go ahead
hey tazzy hello how are you i'm doing
great thanks for asking how are you
doing good how was your christmas uh
pretty good um chilled out kind of just
floated through both the days called the
mom it was cool how about you it was
good cooked some food drank some drinks
oh [ __ ] yeah get lit
i did i'm feeling not so great today oh
that was last night yeah that's true
yeah that's cool
yeah i went to a comedy show last night
and that was fun but
yeah did you spend time with your your
family
no my family
yeah yeah i'm with you there how about
you oh yeah no not me yeah but i would
have i'm just there in oregon
i'm out here mine are in boston oh cool
not cool they suck or what no they're
great oh yeah definitely yeah that's
cool
i already forgot your name oh it's errol
okay tazzy yeah t-a-z-i mm-hmm wild just
that's the real one yeah cool
yeah do you ever ask your parents why
they named you that
no not really
really and time
give it up for tazzy
[Applause]
whose name we don't know
what it means or why it's what's her
name and it's also a weird name it has a
weird name [ __ ] you britney
oh rowan it's like he lives in a van oh
he's got a weird name it's like what did
i ever do to you guys i mean we're just
trying to say her name was weird no
you're right that's fair where does
arrow come from is it a scandinavian
thing i don't know i've never asked
oh you guys have a lot of comments why
are you yeah yeah no it's a joke but um
no i asked one time but he my dad just
said um i like the name
yeah i like the um i go
all right okay dad i'll get your
mustache
yeah
and now here you are here i am
and how did you enjoy uh
what the the whole show so
far you how honest you want me to be
there hans why don't you just say the
first thing that comes in your mind are
you sure
where do you see yourself in five years
oh
that's a great question
probably be on a farm
nice
doing what
hanging out with my animals [ __ ] a
what are you thinking goats sheep
definitely a goat maybe a donkey one of
each yeah you're not much of a herd
animal those are both hurt animals you
know you need friends you chilling with
them yeah barn style what are we doing i
don't know okay a lot of rapid fire
questions from arrow i felt like i was
getting to know her you want to get in
on that hans i want to have everyone get
in on this errol
okay
that's all let's all get to know each
other
yeah let's dial down the defensiveness
oh yeah yeah why are you being hostile
my bad
am i
well uh do you go on a lot of dates
nowadays
um
i don't know what you think's a lot hans
you know everything's relative what is
real
we're all living on a planet i mean i've
dated some people sure i date people yes
i do i do that's awesome it is yeah
you you love animals
i do yeah i want to live on a farm
eventually that's [ __ ] awesome and uh
where would you where would you put this
farm in texas or
it's probably gonna be texas yeah
and would you have errol work for you
maybe you could be a farmer
oh very handy you have experience yeah i
don't know the first thing about having
a farm so
yeah no you'd have to do the farm part
but i could keep stuff going i'm going
to like working on machinery and you
know manual labor or whatever okay well
excuse me
yeah first thing about having a farm you
got to want to have a farm and you've
already got that tazzy and we very much
appreciate your farm farm love
uh
tazzy what do you do for work
uh i'm in marketing
that's gonna be a bridge yeah you're
gonna have to yeah
yeah that's cool though you can get a
lot of money you can market your farm
hey come to the farm that's the plan
just make a lot of money at a donkey
dude
that's a lofty goal
but doable
i stopped at a van they go other
people's got farms i'll just go use
theirs and then when it gets stupid i'll
move on
yeah it's pretty good
i grew up in communes so i know how
people get when they all come together
yeah it's not as good as you think
tell us about that weird sounds
community oh sure i mean i didn't grow
up in them but i grew up in a community
that had a lot of communes because it
was a community that was like a uh
refuge for like uh draft dodgers like
groups of basically hippies how old are
you 36 holy [ __ ]
yeah there are a lot of draft dodgers
and the great gold four i talk to people
outside my own age you know have friends
other places just get interested in
people you know what i mean so they
started the community in the 60s
70s yeah
yeah they basically made a deal with the
indians to like leave them
let them just be chill and they won't
build [ __ ] and be like you know big
[ __ ] and they fell for it again
kind of it's pretty nice it's actually
classic air it's where all your weed
comes from so
no we're one of the good ones we swear
[Music]
and uh you yeah it is like that it is
for sure like that but i mean what else
are you gonna do what do you either
what do you what would you claim you to
be
asian wait what just floating by i'm
like not really here or yeah really land
here hey man we're just gonna build on
your land but we won't build too much
why are you harsh mamella
like that's what it looked like in the
70s uh but
would you uh ever go on a commune and
live in a commune wouldn't that be kind
of fun
i think i get into that yeah
so let's just say you guys are specific
are you a newly married couple and it's
your first day at your new commune and
you're just getting to know
the neighborhood where you turn a guy
like me on you know how i do it hans i
like that and there's like animals
running around
you might see a neighbor or two let's
just set a picture and let's put you
guys in there and see what happens
binoculars and action okay well we were
looking i mean we're at a farm right
that's where we're at at commune
yeah a new commune which is a farm but
there's a main building farming commune
that's it
action
so uh did you milk the goats yet today
uh no i don't really do that
we gotta make cheese somehow oh yeah
someone should make cheese for sure
i would eat cheese for sure and i think
i know some people who know how to make
cheese
i'll hang out yeah i'll make some goats
you want to milk some ghosts today let's
do it yeah [ __ ] egg do we have any
goats look over there
goats
use my what
thank you
oh my god are those sh no are those no
other goats holy [ __ ]
yeah that's uh
[Music]
give them a looksie go ahead
yup see them they're over there
more goats over here huh [ __ ] we better
they're everywhere
i knew this was a bad idea it's a peg me
goat farm now [ __ ] and seen well give it
up for that lovely scene that they did
together you're welcome
a lot of milking goats you're amazing
you milk goats goat cheese i guess
yeah it's a thing
where do you shop whole foods or
h-e-b
oh
because you're reasonable texas
middle-class
you're down with the people you're one
of us i am arrow where do you shop
hell fits
exclusively no i did not expect that
i'll go into whole foods they got a
great like salad bar for i mean it's
just a plethora of [ __ ] food they
make it's kind of gross really i mean
can you afford it or
nope you're right
so you i've been able for it i yeah i
just i go in there i just eat it i just
take little forks and i just kind of you
know just nibble until someone gets mad
food should be free right
i mean
that is a way you could look at things
and probably make things a lot better
yeah you know at least people would be
eating but yeah no you're right yeah
[ __ ] the people that made the food
no i'm just kidding yeah you're going
deep
no that's awesome i just thought that
with a goat cheese that maybe shopped at
whole foods um
goat cheese [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah it's not as good though
that's that's a very clean story you
know
what you got again
heb is like walmart it's like one step
down from walmart
oh [ __ ] this is live next episode is
gonna be in oklahoma
you might have burned a bridge here
holy [ __ ]
no well rogan's gonna talk to you about
that one
hgb no we don't [ __ ] with heb they got a
lot of stuff in there you can buy
furniture
you can get vaccines
it's a great place
it's just like i just know where you get
your furniture
no i actually i live in a van as well so
that's the [ __ ] thing in austin
there's a lot of it's a nice city to
just float around in
i mean it is i i don't i mean i would
feel like a [ __ ] idiot if i signed a
lease i just would yeah with that warm
running water and electricity just such
an idiot
making the homeless trendy again yeah i
mean i guess if you spend your days
around running water and doing that all
day then yeah you'd be really bummed out
but well the good news is that if you go
on a date with either errol or me you
can write it off on your taxes
sit right here i mean i'm wearing a
button down come on you're the one who
wants to do this oh look at this guy
changing the format of the show [ __ ]
there are no rules everything is fluid
hold me down we shouldn't come on you
want to be held down to
strict
rules and stuff it'll be fun
uh no i'll do the questions and you can
just sit here and have a nice day i'd
rather not like to
look at it i think into it i think i
respect tazzy too much to just steal her
man sounds like a dude who knows what
he's saying
you're a woman
or whatever however ownership of people
work you reading it uh but uh yeah so
lit you got lit
uh yesterday
lit uh what drugs do you enjoy doing on
christmas
is it a white christmas live i don't
know if i can say it
yeah you don't want to tell people what
drugs you do
that's a lot hard ones needles do you
like um code
let's do code
um
no
i played the fifth
but you drank a lot of alcohol yesterday
what did you drink tequila or
there was a lot of tequila involved yes
heb tequila no it was some good like
christmas oh so you admit hgb tequila is
not good good christmas though
yeah
yeah
oh really
if only i had been to more hebs i'm
missing out on so much
no i love i love alcohol
you drink a lot of what tequila tequila
nice
and who are you with who are you getting
crunk with
my other uh christmas orphans nikki and
mickey you're two nickies
getting drunk
two mickeys and them oh the nicki's
nikki uh what what about you what did
you do what how what drugs did you do
yesterday i smoke weed and exclusively
just weed i'll [ __ ] with mushrooms a
little bit but you know it's the same
thing really yeah it's just super weak
same track yeah yeah same
but no just not a little weed it's
getting i guess it gets me too high i'm
going through it now you know i've
smoked a lot of i didn't smoke weed
until i was 33 then i smoked a lot of
weed for the last three years just to
feel it out because i feel like i was
missing out yeah how do you know if you
don't try it for three years yeah so i
went at it ended up in a van and now i'm
coming back you know he's a success
story
he's a commercial for weed coach too i
have like a rv and i have two three rvs
basically which is a weird thing i dare
you
yeah dude they're [ __ ] me up i wrote
my letter i wrote my
mom and dad a letter saying i got turned
in i'm so sorry
derek they got to me man my mom smoked a
gestapo
there's uh
basically you know
hitler youth
uh nice okay
yeah so
uh
where do you guys see yourselves going
on a date maybe the green belt i feel
like would be good for errol to get him
with some air
what
he could sleep there that night they say
that's how they call it oh yeah sure
yeah yeah probably near where you park
your van right
uh yeah i was turned on to a place
called
or
festive
beach or whatever which is a few times
there but i also chill at this coffee
shop called flak track they're cool as
[ __ ] and there's like nice neighborhoods
back there
i mean i i stay out until 2 a.m and then
i float into a neighborhood i go to bed
i get up i go to a coffee shop i do art
i do this and i go i'm not really taxing
society you know what i mean yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] up it's a pretty minimalist
thing i mean i always say you are
homeless if you take minimalists
seriously
okay
yes
i mean hopefully one of you guys will
get to house errol in your neighborhood
tonight i'm house i feel good it's
everyone else's guilt and shame that's
[ __ ] rubbing on me i mean i love i
live in a van too bro i don't know i
don't know why you keep hitting me it's
like why don't we just crashing at
someone's house now so he feels like
he's better now plus you're an [ __ ]
i'm uh you're not a [ __ ] freightliner
i miss i'm yeah i look down on your
family
i become civilized and domesticated no
you it looks good on youtube like the
house watch the whole thing it really
freshened you up
nice yeah it's amazing what shelter can
do for a human [ __ ] a oh my gosh
tell you what anyways thank you guys so
much for coming on a date with us thank
you live in person
thank you errol yeah thank you
[Applause]
we got one more lady in the bucket whose
name is not nikki apparently so nikki
did not sign up nikki would you like to
go on a date with a female
or a male
what is your name amanda
nikki
he's coming up oh my god
i don't know what's going on so your
name is amanda
oh no your name's yeah your name's
amanda her name's nikki
so yeah it wasn't two nicki's one amanda
and one nicky and one tassie sitting at
a table thank you guys for coming uh
and do we have a male volunteer anyone
want to go on a date with amanda or
whatever her name is
amanda
jack
jack why don't you go on a date again
with amanda
give it up for this guy he's playing
both sides of the field tonight
he's so excited this time
his aunt's giving him some much needed
liquid courage
i just finished my drink cody meant
nothing to me um
we don't talk about him love you
you go first oh all right well happy
birthday oh my goodness what do you all
got planned tonight
well i don't want to hype on what tazzy
was talking about but it's definitely
not drugs oh
god forbid
that would be terrible just alcohol just
american american style
well where are you from
i'm from a tiny little town about an
hour north of dallas
what's the town called
little elm have you been there
so many times no no uh nice how was it
growing up in a little tiny town it was
awful i'm here now where are you from
i'm from here oh the greatest city in
the world a unicorn
yeah that's not too many true austinites
yeah i know we're
we are a breed
interesting at that i'm out of questions
what do you do i already know what you
do for work what do you do what do you
do for work
uh i work at a children's trauma
hospital doing x-ray
an amazing person oh my goodness and
time
give it up for
nikki
and
jack oh my gosh it's me
good to have you back jack thanks
sitting in the same seat
this is just
a merry-go-round for you we should the
show should be called jack
judges you
are you a good person or not
i guess it depends on who you ask i'm
gonna go with yes though there we go
yeah confidence like a solid eight on
the scale of good she's terrible a good
person on stage so you work at a trauma
hospital
so
is that like
fresh injuries or
like
like a lot of strikes and
bruises and
yes okay wow lots of bruises
jesus i i would love to uh you know
delve more into this
i'm ready hospital go ahead what's the
worst thing you've seen come in
um i a child stuck a light bulb up his
butthole and i asked him
why he did that he immediately with no
hesitation said because it felt good
when he's right he's right was it good
to see you again
yeah thankfully it wasn't broken so
that's nice
it was intact yeah it was like a little
uh a nightlight what a gentle lover he
was small what uh what end did he stick
up his ass first oh the uh metal or the
the big end big guy you know wow ooh
children's butt plus and he's he needs
to learn about uh [ __ ]
etiquette i feel like he nailed it
he just couldn't get it out he probably
needed pretty thrilled
he had a great idea he was in a great
mood the whole time
he had a light bulb moment yes
yes
if only cody was there he could have
helped dig around in that little boy's
[ __ ]
[Music]
you want to go fishing
[Laughter]
like a true pedophile
um
but uh the great thing about working in
a trauma hospital with children is that
it happens to children which is like
even worse than just normal
trauma no
no you know you hate children no they're
normally pretty good spirited about the
whole thing whereas adults just cry the
whole time
[Music]
now i kind of want to get injured to
prove you wrong
i'll be there let me know thank you this
is great to have a
doctor no
x-ray
you can see what's going on and tell
someone else to do something about it
when you realize you wanted to work at a
trauma hospital like when was the light
bulb moment that's where all the cool
stuff happens
but like when like
i don't know you just kind of like one
day you were like oh i said this is
boring i want to go somewhere where it's
not boring and there i was you know
there you were at a hospital there i was
at the trauma hospital
yeah there you go when did you learn you
wanted to work in mortgages oh god i
don't
no i i i never i never thought i did i
wanted to be an actor yeah and then yeah
that's why i'm so vibrant ah yeah uh but
then i was like acting oppressed
but then i was like um money is good too
so money yeah yeah i mean
that'll get you there yeah [ __ ] much
love a man that gives up on his dreams
[Laughter]
a good old money pursuer
um so
you
uh it's your birthday
and you're not gonna do drugs after this
but if you were
which drugs would you do on your special
day after christmas birthday which would
have been weird in an ideal word world
you know
the fun ones so
we're hoping it's molly but we just
found out it might be meth so we're just
going to take that gamble
real wild and weird that's the white
ones are the goal
yeah yeah white christmas we love it
snowing yeah in this 80 degree weather
sounds awesome maybe you could uh offer
it up to us before the next show maybe
we could
i roasted myself oh my gosh it's a live
stream
yeah i mean uh cocaine is always good um
you enjoy it i write down your request
and we'll see what the crowd can do
let's let's order it from the waiter
uh so you guys are gonna
party up uh where where do you go after
this do you go to a dance club or do you
go to
uh cafe lazarus or
cafe lazarus
yeah
that's a brewery
it's a fun brewery
so not there yeah you wouldn't want to
go there um
i think we're just going to usually go
to east austin and then see what happens
it's all up in the air what i like to do
is take hard drugs and then go anywhere
i want go where the wind blows man
that's always i'm always in the best
place to make decisions go where the
drugs are after i do drugs
you got to keep doing drugs it's never
you're chasing the dragon all night yeah
so probably sidebar for being honest oh
right across the street absolutely
yeah there's lots of drugs there
lots of shady characters right next door
so you can get in your car right after
go home whole bag of baby powder and go
home
so jack do you uh consume a lot of uh
drugs
uh actually fun fun fact i'm allergic to
weed so now oh my god
that's one of my fallbacks what a loser
i know right do you work in a mortgage
company as well
yeah
what a square
so what do you mean by allergic like you
can't eat it or smoke it yeah i tried
about eight or nine times before i was
like gosh i really am passing out and
throwing up every time i do like take
weed any way shape or form that just
sounds like you did too much not that
you're allergic
[ __ ]
you sound like a cop is
he's actually undercover right now yeah
you can tell by the
the crappy [ __ ] i love it you're like so
white your body's like anything fun i'm
gonna throw it up
i do fun things i don't know mushrooms
are great what's the funnest thing
you've done on mushrooms
uh
yeah
no no this is you on shrooms
have you ever taken shrooms and done
someone's mortgage
[Music]
maybe
no no no uh i think the craziest thing
i've done on shrooms is probably
go down on uh in san marcos on the river
uh with the little shoots yeah that's
fine on mushrooms i don't remember any
of it
we were drunk it was great that's how
you know you're having fun you're like i
don't remember what just happened and i
never will just wake up with bruises
like oh my god did i fall off and
everybody's like
that's right yeah that's why your ass
hurts
it's because of you falling off it's the
craziest thing you've done on your
fun snow
you know you go out on town just you can
say cocaine can i yes oh no it's a live
stream i think it's isn't that tos i
don't know no you can say cocaine
i have no stories
sorry
my bad no stories of anything
no
any uh any fun experiences on the snow
snow or the what the white white
the mayonnaise
the real snow i almost skied off the
side of a mountain once
yeah
that's fun and that was the last time i
did that
and that's my only story that's the only
if you fell off would you have done a
flip
just to be like oh i just would have
been like ah
that's unfortunate
i'm glad that you didn't fall off so
that you could continue to do more snow
um
[Music]
so you you know how to ski
clearly not she almost fell in that
mountain
it was your first time uh-huh
and someone took you up on a cliff
yeah i nailed the bunny slopes so i
wouldn't do the real thing mistake
you have to like
turn
yeah i didn't know how to do that so
maybe that's a metaphor for your for
your day today maybe stick to the bunny
slopes pick a plan yeah stick to it fall
off a cliff aka
i-35
oh my god
i think i because you have a joke about
that
oh yeah i uh i don't drink but when i
used to i took a bird scooter and this
is when i realized it was getting out of
hand was because i took a bird scooter
down the highway two weekends in a row
it's like on the front end
road i think there were stories about
you on reddit i saw him
[Laughter]
a reddit user i loved this date already
what's your favorite subreddit
i just found one called med dizzy
is that where you medicate children and
then they get really dizzy and you film
them no it is a medical subreddit but
it's all the crazy things but
kids are [ __ ] stupid as a good one
that's a fun one
and then
all the ones the [ __ ] name are pretty
good so crazy [ __ ] videos this is a
really good one those three probably my
top three right now i bet that's
important because you see so much you're
like i need something
to that level yeah gotta really hype it
up or what's the point yeah you saw a
kid with a light bulb in his ass where
do i go from there a little kitten is
not gonna do anything
no
just your favorite sub reddit uh the the
joke one that's called people [ __ ]
dying it's like but it's just like
kittens and that's another [ __ ]
title
yeah but it's cute but that you know
like there's just some good ones like
just no mill it's just like horrible
stories about your mother-in-law i've
seen that one great yeah it's a good one
you know don't you hate your
mother-in-law oh wait no you live in a
van yeah i'm single yeah
so are you
yeah that's why you're on my show
relax
uh any questions for this lovely couple
brittany
um
again i just want to hear the bad things
about y'all
you go first oh gosh
it's allergic to nothing bad about me
what's the maddest you've ever been at
someone
i was on shrooms going down a river in
san marcos and they literally jumped on
top of me and smashed my head against
something who there's this guy named
thor
fun fact he looked like thor
six foot five so he jumped into your
inner tube yep and flipped me and made
me hit my head on a rock
so this was like the time that you said
was so fun and you don't remember any of
it yeah maybe that's why you were
concussed
probably but like i got so mad at him
and then i had a great time after i
stopped being mad because the shroom's
kicked in
yes
so if i want to do something [ __ ] up
to you
i should wait until you do shrooms and
then just mess up your life [ __ ] out of
you
and then i'll completely forget and just
have a great time after did he explain
why he did that
no he was my boss so i had to accept it
uh he was probably
wilding out
my bartending job your dad's also named
thor
david what about you uh nikki uh what
does uh what is the maddest you've ever
gone at someone
um i woke up in the morning and my
ex-boyfriend had used my couch as an
ashtray with him and all of his friends
while i was sleeping
what a trashy dude he probably has
covered right now oh 100 100 with
your uh your ex
both of them who are we pointing at
oh
they have covered together
[Laughter]
me too
putting it out or just ashing all the
things oh my gosh
what is it like a nice couch
yeah oh [ __ ] him yeah like one of those
two grand couches you know it's from
ikea
[Laughter]
so let's say that you wake up and you
see your couch covered in ashes and burn
marks and
there's jack sitting on that sleeping on
that couch
what what do you say and how does it go
down action
hey jack
why are you such an [ __ ]
what do you mean i was just i was with
friends
this is the titanic this is my couch get
the [ __ ] out of my house
but
only one only one babe babe we've done
so great together like we two years in a
relationship come on
can't
it's just couch i'll buy a new one
but you don't have a job
look
selling drugs is a job i'll make the
money but you do all the drugs i don't
even smoke weed
you do all the drugs [ __ ]
and scene
jack
taking a lesson from cody
his ex-boyfriend doing all the drugs
uh thank you guys so much for coming up
and doing this
uh this has been a great date
hopefully you guys
have a better success than cody and jack
does
uh that was the show thank you guys so
much for coming out uh thank you
brittany for coming out anything you'd
like to plug or anything instagram for
the two
you know 10 people out there it's
britney led on instagram okay bye
britney led she runs a show at oppa
she runs a show at uh other places all
over the city uh give it up for brittany
ledesma one more time
[Music]
thank you guys so much for coming out
drive safe have a good night thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
[Music]
and
[Music]
goes by